so first off I just want to thank you
all for having me here it's really great
to have this event here in Austin as we
were talking about before I've actually
spoken that my data's in other parts of
the country it's really really great to
have it here at home right and in this
community so really excited about that
anyone who's ever seen me speak before I
usually give technical talks but this
time I have a lot of other things on my
mind these days so I was going to talk
about that so and I've kind of been a
question/answer style some of the crazy
questions that come to me over and over
and over and over again and kind of how
maybe a little bit of discussion around
that right so we're gonna talk about
data science and how to build data
science projects how to deploy data
science teams all of these things like
that and I'll just kick it off now so
first off who do you think you are
Katrina right sorry I get this one quite
a bit okay so I'll tell you who I am
actually I was kind of given this really
beautiful introduction before I'm a
longtime Python ista I love the Python
ecosystem I actually got started back in
1998 was when I first started
programming in Python I was back for way
before we had this amazing ecosystem so
working with like number a and numeric
and all of those things like that I'm
old-school like that right I actually
got my first job working at an
artificial and artificial intelligence
research and development company back in
2001 and yes we were a Python shop so
believe it or not that's actually how
they found me so I was an officer in the
ACM chapter on campus they gave a talk
about Python I immediately started
gushing about how much I loved the
language and I got a job so this is kind
of where I got started since then I went
on to get my PhD I continued to study
artificial intelligence went on to do a
whole bunch of other things that were
already mentioned right I have applied
machine learning in a lot of different
places right everything from oil and gas
to finance to business intelligence to
insider threat detection
a lot of different things right chatbots
question-answer systems I feel like I
kind of run the gamut right so that's
kind of my whole story and then as far
as community building it was mentioned
that I am on the board of directors for
an unfocused very honored to have been
nominated and elected into that position
and something I take very seriously so
please ever mentioning before if you
want to come say hi tell me more about
yourself I am very interested in helping
to foster community so who the heck is
CloudFlare right we've mentioned it a
couple of times for those who don't know
who CloudFlare is they're leading
security performance and reliability
company a lot of different we have about
200 million Internet properties on our
network we have metals out in about a
hundred and ninety two cities all across
the world and we have about what is it
ten percent of Fortune 1000 companies
are using at least one CloudFlare
product right so we have this huge
network or primarily known for security
I think people have heard of us mostly
in that context we provide DDoS
protection bot management things like
that VPN people have heard of like one
point one point one point one it's a
pretty popular and warp all these other
things like that we have some really
good products that are out there and a
lot of things that are actually
available for free so definitely check
it out okay people may also be aware of
who we are because of our law are a lava
lamp wall not sure if anybody's ware of
this reason I put this up here it's kind
of a cool thing we have cameras trained
on the lava lamps to take pictures of
the movement of the lava lamps and that
is used to seed our pseudo run a random
number generator that is then used
across the entire company so a lot of
people are familiar for that and it's
actually really funny because when
people come visit the office in San
Francisco they're like should I you like
not walk in front of the lava lamps and
stuff like that actually adding your
picture in there creates more entropy
and it's really really good for that run
a random number generator so it's a it's
a very good thing to do actually so any
questions about CloudFlare please let me
know we're just getting started
data science team over at CloudFlare
luckily I have a couple of my team
members here today as well but so I'm
not gonna talk about CloudFlare I'm
gonna talk about all this other stuff
right okay so wait so what is your team
do again okay I get this one a lot okay
I my team is actually especially a
CloudFlare we're in a kind of a strange
location we are in the finance
department so the number of times I've
tried to explain to somebody I'm not an
accountant is actually pretty funny and
then also I've been in under CTOs we've
been I've had data science organizations
that are off on their own
under IT under a lot of different places
right under operations even right so
data science can exist in a lot of
different places within an organization
and so but I think it's really important
to make sure that we're on the same page
of what my team actually does right we
are the ones that do predictive
decision-making right in an automated
way and that's the easiest way to
describe what we do so we take business
requirement and we're going to take the
data that we have to support that do a
lot of exploration in that area right
build a machine learning model or some
other sort of model or create some sort
of insights create rules whatever we
have to do and then we will deploy that
out into a production system monitor it
and keep it going right I thought this
was a really funny picture by the way I
stole this from Microsoft so don't blame
me for the picture but but it has the
start at the beginning and then it has
the end at the bottom I've actually
never been on a data science project
that ended so because there's retraining
and redeployment right and you know
models drift over time and we have all
of these things that are going on right
and so it's not as simple as building a
procedural set of code that's gonna move
us into you know the set of features
that we know are completely reliable and
completely stable and are going to work
forever right is it is going to change
the ecosystem is going to
the inputs are gonna change people are
gonna adapt in response to the the
things that are coming out of the
machine learning model right so we have
to keep on going through this process
over and over and over and over again
and constantly refine so I just always
think it's funny because you know people
are like oh well we'll just take this
guy's data scientist off this project
and we're gonna move over here and and
then you know three months later
everyone's wondering why did this
project suddenly blow up and why is
everything all crazy and you know all of
those things like that right it's
because we have to keep on going right
it's a it's a it's a process
so my team also works with a lot of
other teams obviously right we have to
work with the business people we have to
work with the product managers we have
to work with the engineers we have to
work with the application engineer so we
have to work with back-end engineers we
have to work with data engineers means
that we're also gonna have to work with
DevOps in order to keep a system that's
up and running always big shout out to
the DevOps people right keeping these
things on the rails is a really an
important important job so I just want
to make sure that it's clear none of
this happens by itself we're not we
don't work in a silo we have to work
with a lot of different things and
anyone who's ever worked with a data
scientist or you know several beyond
this audience have worked with me we ask
a lot of questions right so that's what
we do all right so you are an engineer
so why is your team writing code this is
actually what I get from leadership all
the time believe it or not where they're
amazed at the number of resources that
it takes to create a successful data
science team right we're gonna need
development environments we're gonna
need cloud environments or we're gonna
need compute we're gonna need access to
data we need sand boxes we need all of
these different things that are going on
all the other teams that I was
mentioning in the last slide it's it's a
much bigger bigger picture right so one
of my favorite quotes about data
scientists we're also known as the folks
who are better engineers than
statisticians and better statisticians
than engineers depending on who you talk
to people will claim I am neither but I
maintain that it's a very fun
space to work in because you do get to
ride that that boundary between
mathematician and an engineer in my
opinion so open source can we really do
that the horror on so many people's
faces when they realize the data science
team is using all open-source
technologies is amazing and immediately
I get sent to go talk to the legal
department and I immediately have to go
explain to CTOs and all these things
like that that open source is going to
be safe right so some of the concerns
that people talk about about legal
liability so are people if people are
injecting proprietary software into an
open-source project even if even if
we're not aware of it we had nothing to
do with it
companies we are legally liable these
are things that you know especially
administrators are going to have to keep
an eye on right licensing compliance big
one obviously we have all want to you
know keep it all aboveboard reliability
is one that I think that people talk
about in communities sometimes it can be
really tempting to change ap is very
quickly not realizing that these silent
people out here are all using your
software and it makes big changes on the
other side that they may or may not be
aware of before the changes happen okay
quality risks in quality risks one of
the big things that I want to mention in
this area really comes back to security
security risks are a big problem
CloudFlare is a security company above
and beyond anything else right the
amount of time that we spend reviewing
software for security risks is
astounding okay so in particular we are
very very concerned about not
introducing security risks into our
software because it's going to affect
all those 200 million Internet
properties that I just mentioned that
are on the CloudFlare network right
support things like that what if a
project is sunsetted right and we have a
heavy dependence on it
what happens to us are we suddenly
you're gonna have to own this are we
going to fork it
create our own repository are we going
to you know what are we going to do if
this project goes away and what is the
chance of that happening right so some
of the things you look for is an active
community space are people actually
engaging in the process do they have a
lot of open tickets and a lot of open
issues do they have a lot of you know
people chattering on the projects things
like that does it look like they have
some financial support things like that
and it can be really be tricky right to
really get that buy-in from from
leadership organizations however
especially in the data science space I
just want to be clear we're talking a
little bit about the PI data ecosystem
this is the genie that is not going back
into the bottle this is the reality of
what we work with every single day and
it is what people are learning to work
with in order to be get into this field
this is the grand equalizer that I don't
think you can avoid it at this point in
time in data science and so we argue
it's going to stay open right
and it's also especially for retention
efforts that we want to retain top
talent we have to pay attention to this
area and we have to embrace it I'm
obviously a huge fan of open source I
wouldn't be working with them focus if I
wasn't and and a very big advocate for
for projects I don't contribute code
very often anymore but I definitely am
much more involved in the community side
but very very big fan and I am very
interested fostering those relationships
so that industry and open source can
have a relationship that is not
parasitic and that is also and also very
healthy too moving forward the the goals
that we all have in mind right so this
is my favorite one can't you just make
your model do whatever right like this
is the question I probably get the most
often and have for the last decade right
like this is so simple why can't your
model just do what we that we want it to
do right
there are a lot of other comments and
questions that I feel fall under this
same category by the way okay so there
is always the you know I have this
really really great idea for a feature
that you just gonna absolutely kill it
and absolutely everyone's excited about
data science and I think that we should
interpret it that way right we're all in
the same we're all in the same team and
it's nice to have input from other
people on the other hand it also can
become overwhelming because so many
people want to get involved and so many
people want to be a part of it one of my
favorite co-workers always describes it
as like when you're building a house you
know you don't necessarily want the
electrician working on the plumbing
system and you don't necessarily want
the plumber working on the roof and all
these different things like that people
we all have to come together to make
successful projects happen right but at
the same time I just want to make sure
that there are ways that we can foster
better relationships between partners
right that we're all working on this you
know this project together so want a
thing to remember right I love this
quote essentially all models are wrong
some are useful right very important to
remember attributed to statistician
George box and this is something that I
think is absolutely true that no matter
how good a machine learning model is it
is going to get things wrong no matter
what
what is our tolerance for the machine
learning model getting things wrong we
we cannot help it it will happen I can
guarantee it
even with you know 99.99999% confidence
you're gonna hit that point zero zero
zero one percent of the time right and
then like I said inputs change stimulus
changes so what happens in these new
novel instances where suddenly we don't
know what's gonna what how the model is
going to react to these new instances
that we haven't seen in the past right
so one of the things that I really
really really recommend to people is to
take risk mitigation plans very
seriously
okay machine learning models rarely get
to function by themselves without any
kind of guardrails in place on either
side right so we want to make sure that
we have a risk mitigation plan make sure
that we're getting good inputs make sure
that we're getting reasonable outputs
making sure that our machine learning
model is also augmented with business
logic so that we're not doing anything
that's obviously wrong right and it
seems pretty obvious but at the same
time I think that sometimes data science
is billed as being this magic bullet
that I can do anything and that is magic
right and that we are always able to
create perfect models that are going to
and you know make everything all better
and we're all going to become rich and
retire and do open source full-time
right but that's probably not the case
in the real world we're going to have to
be very very careful about how we're
using it and also evaluate whether or
not the application that we're writing
this machine learning model for is
actually worth all the effort and time
work patience energy all of those other
things that are necessary but there's a
real payoff for it not just because it's
cool okay and so and then one thing I
just want to make sure people understand
please resist the urge to start
manipulating your data in order to get
the result that you want there is a
certain amount of tuning that we can do
there's a certain amount of ways that we
can boost data things like that that are
well-known techniques but when you start
putting fake data in in order to get
what you want or you start doing
something really strange like adding a
feature that includes the you know very
biased opinions of one of your
co-workers so that you can get it to do
what you want it to do that's like no
just stop okay
don't do it and then always remember
transparency education and please let's
keep things civil we're all on the same
team here okay which those of you who
have worked with me know that I don't
always abide by that last one but I try
my best all right what the heck is going
on with our AWS bill this is the one
that I spent
probably the majority of my time
answering right did your team really
just run a $40,000 AWS job the answer is
yes we did it this goes back to the fact
that some people really underestimate
what it takes to create a data science
ecosystem and just how much compute
we're talking about in particular I want
to just really call out I'm looking at
you deep learning okay that is the one
in particular that just blows budgets
out of the water
okay and so really keep in mind like
should we be doing clouds should we be
doing on-prem what is the actual
trade-off there and what's going on and
ultimately in a lot of cases we have
decided to do training for deep learning
models on prim because it does end up
being cheaper by the way so and then
also just want to mention we are data
scientists let's build some models to
predict our costs I actually have done
that several times right they work it
helps it helps a lot and it also
prepares people for what they're about
to see okay because the cost I think
sometimes can really really surprise
people do we need to worry about the
rise of the evil AI okay it's like I put
this kind of tongue-in-cheek in here but
I get asked this question a ridiculous
number of times okay so at conferences
on panels in business meetings all these
things like that it comes up a lot and
so my answer is always usually the stock
answer that I'm gonna start worrying
about the evil AI once my insurance
company can actually route me to the
right place when I'm giving it voice
direction right I mean let's be real
about the system's most of the systems
that we actually interact with that have
some sort of AI system in them we want
to throw them out the window right we
want to just beat up our laptop and
throw them out the window but I do think
there are some concerns that we should
keep an eye on okay so introducing
harmful bias into machine learning
models right one of the big things that
we're doing is we're mining the past in
order to find predictive futures right
do we want to repeat the past though do
we want to reinforce those things
we have seen in the past and one of the
big call-outs I'm gonna put here it's HR
systems that look for good hires things
like that do we necessarily want to be
using machine learning to reinforce the
same people that we've hired over and
over and over and over again and get no
diversity of thought okay and so
competing machine algorithms that end up
optimizing each other to the point that
they've actually just squeezed every
last dollar out of a particular field
right we're starting to see that in the
housing market where suddenly we have a
situation where we're taking the output
of other machine learning systems as
input and stimulus into other machine
learning systems and we're just trying
to optimize each other out right and it
just becomes a very interesting
competing game and kind of loses sight
of the bigger picture right
creation of self-reinforcing information
bubbles I you know won't get into that
too deeply I think we all know what I'm
talking about there and our tolerance
for false positives and false negatives
right is how what how much are we like I
always I probably see at least once a
week on Facebook or something like that
somebody's like wow look at my crazy
recommendation that this online
marketplace gave me right how funny is
this haha right it's funny until it's
your cancer diagnosis right it's funny
until it's your mission critical system
that sends your plane off in the wrong
direction right it's you know these are
really really like what are we willing
to put up with and what is the risk that
we're willing to take on by having this
be a part of our society right and then
privacy and control over personal data
is a really big deal right who's seeing
our data who's using it who's profiting
off of it are we just consumers or are
we part of this society right and then I
just want to mention this one because
it's really important and something that
comes up pretty often do you realize
that you're the only woman at this
conference in this meeting on this
project in this room things like that it
happens all the time okay and so first
off I'm just gonna let you guys know yes
I am always aware
I'm extremely aware when that happens
okay it never needs to be pointed out to
me and please you know let's not turn it
into like you know what is the intention
behind that because my mind can spin out
for hours about what what people are
trying to say when they ask these
questions right but I do want to remind
people right that there are some pretty
steep wrestling statistics around this
right women and technology is still a
problem creating space for each other
being able to create communities where
people are able to participate and I do
want to call out even open-source
communities sometimes can be a very very
difficult place for women to be able to
feel comfortable contributing right and
so can we make space for each other
right and then obviously I'm not the
only woman here in this audience right
but at the same time I do want to
mention that you know let's all agree to
make some space for each other right and
also for all of us as a community can we
agree that we're gonna mess things up
we're gonna get things wrong we're gonna
try and we're gonna fail
we're gonna say the wrong thing we're
gonna do all kinds of crazy things over
the course of our lifetimes and we're
still going to get back up and we're
gonna try again because it's worth it
and we want to keep going forward
towards the goals that we want to get to
okay so I just want to make sure that
we're all have that agreement with each
other and that we're able to move
forward that way and now it's kind of
your turn like I said track 3 11:00 a.m.
please come talk to me I'm sorry I had
to kind of go a little fast but thank
you very much for your attention
[Applause]